but the overarching thing is
nevertheless a kind
of uh mimic optimism
pandemic so uh I mean okay let me ask
you do you think eak to some degree is a
cult Define
cult I think a lot of human progress is
made when you have independent thought
so you have individuals that are able to
think freely
and very
powerful uh mtic systems can kind of
lead to group think there's something in
human nature that leads to like Mass
hypnosis Mass hysteria we start to think
alike whenever there's a sexy idea that
captures our minds and so it's actually
hard to like break us apart like pull us
apart diversify thought so I'm to that
degree to to which degrees is everybody
kind of ch chanting eak eak like the
sheep and Animal Farm well first of all
it's fun it's rebellious right like uh
you know
many um I I I think we lean into there
there there's this concept of sort of
meta irony right of of sort of being on
the boundary of like we're not sure if
they're serious or not and it's it's
much more playful and much more fun
right like um for example we talk about
thermodynamics being our God right um
and sometimes we do cult-like things but
there's no like ceremony and in robes
and whatnot uh so not
yet uh but ultimately yeah I I mean I
totally agree that it seems to me that
humans want to feel like they're part of
a group so they naturally try to agree
with their neighbors and and find common
ground and and that leads to sort of
mode collapse in the space of ideas
right we used to have sort of one
cultural uh Island that was allowed it
was a typical Subspace of thought and
anything that was diverting from that
Subspace of thought was suppressed or
you were canell right now we've created
a new mode but the whole point is that
we're not trying to have very restricted
space of thought there's not just one
way to think about eak and its many
forks and and the point is that there
are many forks and there can be many
clusters in many islands and I shouldn't
be in control of it uh in any way uh I
mean there's no formal org uh whatsoever
uh I just put out uh tweets and and
certain blog posts and people are free
to defect and Fork if there's an aspect
they don't like and so that makes it so
that there should be a sort of deterr
deterritorialization in the space of
ideas so that we don't end up in one
cluster that's very cult-like um and so
Cults usually the they don't they don't
allow people to defect or start
competing Forks whereas we encourage it
right